It's okay, Mr.
Nishimura. He's been acting
strange ever since we went shopping, so I
figured it out somehow. You
know, Mr. Nishimura. I
like Mr. Nishimura, but
that doesn't mean I like Mr. Hino, Mr. Adachi, Mr. Kasahara,
and everyone else.  I
don't know how that's different,
but I just feel like I'm different from other people. I
wonder if I can kiss Nishimura-san now. [Music] No, Takada-kun,
that's okay.  Well then, no. When
Takada-kun finds
someone, the person he kisses may or may not be me.
But I think it would be better if Takada-kun starts to feel like he wants to kiss someone from the bottom of his heart.
I want to kiss Nishimura-san from the bottom of my heart,
but
[Music]
It's a little suspicious that we're talking alone. Mr. Kasahara-san,
Takada
-kun, let's have a drink together. I'll be there soon. I'll
definitely come right away.  Hey, look, that's enough. That's
really
juice, I think. Let's
go. Let's
talk about what we talked about sometime again, Mr. Nishimura
[Music]